une scène devenue familière dans le sud
de la floride
de longues files de voitures des heures
d'attentes pour subir un test de
dépistage
l'impatience se fait sentir
l'inquiétude aussi la tester pas été
j'ai un fils qui a été déclaré positif à
la coved 19 nous explique cet homme
c'est la raison pour laquelle il vient
se faire tester le comté de miami dade
enregistré le quart de tous les cas
déclarés en floride de la ville de
hampstead est durement touchée ici le
quart de la population vit sous le seuil
de la pauvreté
[Musique]
quelques kilomètres plus loin une autre
file se forme
mais cette fois pour recevoir de la
nourriture des bénévoles distribuent des
denrées gratuite
à la crise sanitaire s'ajoute la crise
économique
ces opérations sont devenues
essentielles dans cette région de la
floride
le va et vient des voitures est
constante en quelques heures
500 boîtes de nourriture se sont envolés
des monnaies
comme steve compte une importante
communauté hispanophone les emplois
dépendent beaucoup du tourisme
la crise sanitaire a frappé cette
industrie de plein fouet son chauffeur
d'hubert n'a pas travaillé depuis plus
de trois mois
c'est une situation très difficile dit
il shannon a perdu son emploi et doit
nourrir ses cinq enfants
des souhaits et non une aide essentielle
pendant qu'elle temps de retrouver du
travail
la recrudescence des cas dans le comté
n'augure rien de bon la distribution de
denrées devra se poursuivre au moins six
mois croit-il
pendant que la crise sanitaire s'étire
en floride les ravages économiques
prennent de l'ampleur
ici louis blouin radio-canada homestead
en floride